[Música]
hablamos ahora de salud del directo
américa de france 24 y por ahí yo me
acompaña en el estudio como siempre más
romeros a la mar bienvenida a feliz
jueves hoy es el día de la visibilidad
de las personas trans y la salud en el
entorno médico juega un papel muy grande
en la lucha por los derechos de este
colectivo mar así es de hecho raúl
quería empezar por algo un hecho que a
mí me sorprendió mucho cuando lo pudimos
leer y comentar en la reacción y es que
durante mucho tiempo ser una persona
trans considerarse una persona trans es
considerada una enfermedad un transtorno
mental algo que cambió sólo en 2019 hace
apenas tres años menos de tres años de
hecho en la oms en el 2019 efe que la
organización mundial de la salud dejó de
considerarlo un desorden mental y de
conducta para considerarlo una condición
de salud sexual que llamó incongruencia
además podemos comentar esto del ritmo
pero al menos digamos que en ese momento
dejó de considerarlo como una enfermedad
es decir que las personas trans tenían
algún tipo de enfermedad que necesitaban
ser diagnosticadas y que
consecuentemente necesitaban ser tratada
o curadas de alguna manera porque pues
al final eso es lo que se entiende como
enfermedad en esa clasificación que
tenía la organización mundial de la
salud ahora internacionalmente ya no se
reconoce así se reconoce como decíamos
como una condición de salud sexual que
igual hay ciertos activismos trans que
siguen denunciando pues que eso sigue
hablando que no es algo que tenga solo
que ver con la salud sexual y que además
pues tampoco tiene por qué considerarse
una incongruencia es decir algo que esté
mal pero bueno lo más importante y lo
que vamos a hablar también ahora es que
eso no significa esa declaración de la
organización mundial de la salud no
significa que haya muchos países o
muchos lugares donde los sistemas
médicos y de salud sigan fiscalizando
los cuerpos y las identidades trans de
maneras en las que las personas que es
género pues nunca lo son y lo peor mar
también hablando de todo eso pues
primero impresionante que hasta 2019 ya
dijeron que evidentemente no es una
enfermedad y segundo a estos centros de
reconversión para las personas también
como homosexuales trans me parece
aberrante que ocurre más cuando se piden
los requisitos médicos para certificar
el cambio de género de una persona
de hecho a eso nos referíamos con lo de
fiscalizar y con lo de tratar o curar
estos centros de transformación o de
reconversión son quizás como el
exponente más grande pero es que en los
países que por ejemplo requieran
cirugías o terapias hormonales para
poder asignar un cambio en el documento
de identidad no es tan distinto al final
de considerar eso considerar las
identidades trans como una enfermedad
por ejemplo en venezuela se necesita un
informe médico para hacerlo en bolivia
se necesita un informe psicológico en
españa hasta el 2021 también se
necesitaban todos esos informes médicos
y sicológicos para poder cambiar la
identidad de género en un documento de
identidad en algunos estados de eeuu
piden las cirugías por ejemplo y en
finlandia tenías que tienes que
demostrar por ejemplo haber estado
hormonas cndh o 'the durante al menos
dos años para poder hacer ese cambio eso
qué significa pues significa medicalizar
cuerpos de personas que quizás no
quieran hormonas lo que quieras no
quieren hacerse la cirugía invalidar
también al final la identidad de una
persona en base a qué tratamientos
médicos está recibiendo esto es una
circunstancia al final
para este tipo de personas y contraviene
lo que estábamos diciendo al inicio de
la organización mundial de la salud de
dejar de considerar las identidades de
las personas trans como una enfermedad y
además marca a quien vive su proceso
como quiere justamente aquí en nuestro
programa directo américa de france 24 no
sé si se acuerda estábamos conversando
con una persona trans considerada
también no binaria ya decía que era pues
una persona en o binaria y decía que
pues cada persona lleva su proceso hasta
donde quiere y necesariamente como usted
lo dice hormonarse u operarse y
cambiarse realmente sus genitales para
poder ser considerada una persona trans
o una persona del sexo con el siguiente
final la identidad al final es una
cuestión de cada persona y debemos dejar
que las personas pues auto determinen
esa propia entidad con la que quieran
reconocerse marc pero también creemos
que la transfobia solamente son pues
improperios que se tiran en la calle
pero no dimensionamos los defectos que
esto tiene en la salud claro de hecho
durante tanto tiempo se ha considerado
lo trans como una enfermedad cuando en
realidad lo que carga a las personas
trans díaz es esa transfobia la
discriminación hasta el punto de hecho
de que puede llegar a costar la vida
recordemos que según la cdh la esperanza
de vida de las mujeres trans en este
caso particular es de 35 años en américa
latina' eso se explica por muchos
factores por ejemplo por asesinatos
transfóbicos por la discriminación
social que acarrea condiciones de
pobreza o de vulnerabilidad pero también
por el acceso a los sistemas de salud
encontramos y recogimos cifras de eeuu
porque en américa latina en el contexto
latinoamericano a veces es un poco más
difícil encontrar este tipo de datos y
vimos que el 19% de la población trans
en eeuu vive sin seguro médico que
también un 19% han visto rechazadas
atenciones a la salud por su identidad
eso es 2 de cada 10 es decir no es una
cifra baja y un factor determinante 30%
un tercio de las personas han llegado a
evitar o retrasar tratamientos o
consultas para no exponerse a
situaciones violentas o discriminatorias
en estos contextos eso tiene
consecuencias obvias para la salud por
ejemplo pues faltará chequeos médicos no
acudir a revisiones que son necesarias
para monitorear y todo esto repetimos en
estados desconocemos qué alcance puede
tener esto en otros lugares del mundo y
pues que como están siempre las cosas y
cómo son las comparaciones si en eeuu
están así pues lamentablemente nuestra
región américa latina' de caridad
podríamos estar mucho peor en este
aspecto pero qué tipo de consecuencias
entonces el mar con lleva esta falta de
acceso a la salud en este colectivo de
personas pues hemos recopilado una
mezcla variada de condiciones de salud
algo dispares que nos sirve al menos
para entender lo que toda esta
transfobia tiene un efecto directo en la
salud de las personas trans empezando
por la salud mental por ejemplo no la
prevalencia de la depresión entre las
personas trans llega a ser 10 veces
mayor que la prevalencia entre la
población general también estamos
hablando de un tipo de condiciones de
salud muy distintas por ejemplo
enfermedades de transmisión sexual la
carga de vih es también mucho mucho más
alta entre población trans que en
personas y género y eso pues además se
suma a la estigmatización que muchas
veces sufren estas personas además
también se ha visto que el riesgo tanto
en hombres como mujeres trans de infarto
de acá y de enfermedades
cardiovasculares pueden llegar a ser el
doble de las personas sin género hay
cierta especulación si eso sucede por
los procesos de hormonación no está
claro muy importante decir que todavía
no está claro ese vínculo pero también
es muy importante decir pues que sobre
todo con las enfermedades
cardiovasculares sabemos que están
estrechamente relacionadas con las
condiciones de vida con la salud mental
con el estrés con la pobreza la
alimentación entonces todos estos son
factores que al final acaban pensando en
la salud y en la vida de las personas
trans además otra cosa importante para
finalizar que nos comentaban cuando
estábamos hablando para preparar esta
sección son personas del colectivo trans
nos comentaban pues que hay muchas veces
que los médicos las personas o
profesionales de la salud ni siquiera
cuentan con la información adecuada para
acompañar ya no solo los procesos de las
personas trans en las citas rutinarias
no se conocen se desconocen los cuerpos
de las personas trans y al final eso
pues también tiene unos efectos sobre la
salud de estas personas y sobre su
propio derecho al acceso a la vida a la
salud y hasta que imagínense ustedes en
un listado el especialista pues que
queda
las personas más muchísimas gracias
entonces por esta sección especial de
salud de hoy el día de la visibilidad
trans precisamente vamos a seguir con
este tema con este invitado